alors d'abord ça fait de nombreuses
années qu'amnesty documente les cas de
torture donc pour vous pas de surprise
sur les pratiques mais est-ce qu'il ya
autre chose dans son rapport qui vous a
surpris déjà que le sénat lui même enfin
donc émettre ce rapport là c'était
demandé quand même depuis de nombreux
mois que vraiment le sénat produit ce
rapport qui ne reste qu'un extrait d'un
rapport complet de six mille six cents
pages qui lui reste un document secret
rappelons-nous donc aujourd'hui on a un
résumé mais oui c'est important que le
sénat qu un comité du sénat dont puisse
sortir ce rapport là ce qui est
important c'est que ce sénat conclu que
les pratiques de torture ont été
inefficaces donc c'est important que les
américains longtemps c'est important que
le monde entier l'entende aussi
contrairement à ce que le dirigeant la
cia ont toujours tout à fait que tout à
la paire temps pour empêcher d'autres
attentats pour pour empêcher une autre
attaque massive absolument essayer est
en campagne internationale mondial cette
année contre la torture donc on a pu
voir que la pratique de la torture en
général c'est plus pour faire taire que
pour faire parler c'est plus pour faire
taire des voix dissidentes c'est plus
pour impressionner et veut museler
d'autres voient donc clairement c'est
illégal c'est contre la dignité humaine
dans ces moments où effectivement faut
s'occuper de la sécurité de ses
concitoyens ce n'est pas en se
rabaissant dans nos institutions de
droit si ces personnes ont commis des
crimes eh bien il faut les mettre devant
des procès et avoir une fierté de nos
institutions de droit mais fort en
torturant oui mais quand même qu'un état
de droit comme les états unis
démocratique reconnaissent quand même
qu'il a usé de la torture c'est quand
même quelque chose mais c'est juste une
étape ou du ceclr manque juste une état
il faudrait en aucun cas qu'on dise
regarder on a fait notre mea culpa le
rapport est sorti c'est restons-en là ce
serait une gravissime gravissime erreur
il faut d'abord la vérité il faut que ce
rapport de six mille six cents pages
soit public et soit connue et soit
vraiment divulguer toutes les parties il
faut juste une opération de relations
publiques seulement vous avez raison il
faut aussi compensations pour les
victimes pensons à toutes ces personnes
là qui ont été torturés qui sont parfois
encore emprisonnés sans aucun chef
d'accusation qui sont parfois dans leur
pays ou autres et à qui on interdit
toute démarche juridique et pensons à
responsabilité qui est responsable de
ces pratiques de torture à quoi deux
niveaux dans le rapport il ya aucun nom
dans le rapport à quel niveau politique
à quel niveau juridique parce que
l'administration américaine a légalisé
ces pratiques de torture en dehors du
droit international des droits humains
donc là effectivement il faut qu'ils
aient un exercice de justice c'est comme
toute violation de droit s'il ya
impunité la série a pourra continuer à
pratiquer le premier ministre elle
rappelle disait aujourd'hui que ce
rapport ne concerne pas le canada est ce
que cela concerne pas tous les pays
occidentaux confirment tous les pays
aussi dans tout la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme a rendu il ya deux ans
il ya cinq mois des rapports accablants
des jugements accablant contre la
macédoine contre la pologne il ya huit
ans même le par leurs parlements
européens déjà parlé complicité pour un
grand nombre de pays européens qui ont
participé indirectement directement à ce
programme là parlons omar khadr au
canada parlons maher arar il ya beaucoup
de canadiens qui ont souffert de ces
pratiques indirecte de torture et à qui
d'ailleurs le gouvernement du canada
sous un jugement de la cour suprême doit
des côtes la trésorerie merci à vous
on